the same is true if with grammar if you
have no experience with the language and
you read a grammar explanation it makes
no impact on you if you have had a lot
of exposure to the language and then you
read an explanation of a structure it's
possible that that might help you notice
that structure once you've noticed that
structure in different situations Reddit
and heard it and been aware of it and
and so forth then because you know sort
of kind of know it you can now learn it
and that sort of transformation from
something that you have subconsciously
sort of acquired to where it becomes
something that you can consciously use
that is a gradual process and not one
that in my opinion we can deliberately
control